here is one of the most articulate
defenses of trump and clear-eyed views
of political philosophy I have heard
from a viral character in years
I'm here to support president Trump
you want to know why I'm here to support
president Trump because they don't be a
black men like this for decades make up
charges and put them so I know Trump is
innocent what do you think about the
indictments oh it's a bunch of
it's going around the country you know
Fanny Willis she's a uh she went to
school with my sister she fully she was
full of so she's a puppet for the
white liberal that is controlling
everything she's in front but the white
liberal back there pulling those strings
telling her what to do
that's what I think about it making a
fool of herself I'm not joking do not
think that I am in any way being ironic
this guy is smarter and more insightful
and has a clearer view of political
philosophy then 97 of the chattering
class